so
doc how do i get sick
do i get sick through respiratory
do i get sick through water i drink do i
get sick through the food i eat do i get
sick through the way i think
how does one get sick there's basically
four mechanisms of getting sick one
injuries right you fall off a cliff and
break your leg
that's a kind of sickness number two
starvation
that's like scurvy that's like berry
berry that's like pellegra
you don't have the nutrients you you
don't have enough collagen you don't
have enough vitamin c
so that the tissues start to break down
and they excrete these poisons
to essentially try to detoxify
so number one injury number two uh
starvation
and then three which is the biggest is
uh you're poisoned so in other words
just like the milk example you poison
the milk
the bacteria come and eat the poison
and it's the same argument as if
if you think because the bacteria are
there they're the cause of the problem
that's like saying you go to a town and
you see fires
and then you see firemen there and so
the firemen must be causing the fires
actually the firemen are there to clean
up the fires
and put out the fires out the bacteria
are there
to biodegrade dead and dying tissue
so why is it dead and dying because it's
been poisoned
with what i mean you want me to knit we
each of us have 120
carcinogenic chemicals in our blood and
urine
and all mother's milk does we're exposed
to electromagnetic fields which we have
1200 studies that show that they do harm
glyphosate is in the air air pollution
cyanide there's lots of ways people are
poisoned
and the final one is we have emotional
toxicity or poisoning
uh or i sometimes say the way we think
because if you think in this way
that the world is out to get you that
that instead of this the world is a
cooperative
venture that's really the model that i'm
trying to bring here
the world is a cooperative venture it's
not this
survival of the fittest model that was
just a construct
once you see it like that that's that's
the terrain
theory that's i i have a healthy terrain
and i'm resistant to sickness so four
ways we get sick
injuries starvation which is scurvy bury
bury
uh this is when you're not getting
enough nutrients collagen
three is poison similar to the story of
the milk and fourth one is
emotional toxicity uh the world is not
out there to get you it's a collab
collaborative efforts and if you look at
the world in a different way you
won't get sick